die letzte Sendung vor der Sommerpause
und es ist mir wirklich peinlich in
welchem Zustand wir das Land
zurücklassen 18 Prozent für die AFD im
Deutschland trennt Schock für alle
anderen und neue Rekord 18 Prozent ohne
dass die Partei dafür irgendwas machen
müsste der ist ja so also
leistungslose transfer-empfänger von
Prozenten sie liegen vor dem grünen
gleich auf mit der Kanzlerpartei SPD und
ihr Erfolgsrezept besteht nach wie vor
nur aus drei Zutaten Angst Wut und
Krisen mehr braucht es nicht klar auf
dem Papier hat die AFD schon so eine Art
Programm aber das lässt sich eigentlich
relativ kurz zusammenfassen ihr werdet
doch alle verarscht von denen
[Applaus]
haben sie gehört die verdammten Eliten
da oben sprach und vor zurück nach Hause
in die Schweiz
die Frau Weide tatsächlich ist der
aktuelle Erfolg der AFD eine
Gemeinschaftsproduktion die Ampel hilft
zum Beispiel em sich mit indem sie sich
wochenlang über Heizungen zofft ja
demnächst im ZDF höckes Helfer
vor allem der heizungsstreit ist ein
würdeloses das restvertrauen in diese
Regierung erschütterndes Theater und die
AFD kann ihr Glück gar nicht fassen 18 %
für eine rassistische völkische in
Teilen ganz offiziell rechtsextreme
Partei deren Abgeordnete in Putins
Propaganda TV auftreten und in jedem
Satz mindestens fünfmal das Wort Deutsch
unterbringen
dass sie das deutsche einfach nicht mehr
wollen sie versuchen das deutsche in
sich zu bekämpfen und bekämpfen
letztlich das Deutsche an sich und
wollen Deutschland und das deutsche
insgesamt loswerden
sagt der deutsche Bernd höcke aus
Deutschland
der höcke der von einem Zitat
vollständigen Sieg der AFD träumt
vollständiger sie kennen sie natürlich
aus dem Kreuzworträtsel 17 Buchstaben
anderes Wort für macht Ergreifung
trotzdem Umfrage Rekorde selbst bei
Markus Lanz beißt man sich inzwischen
die Zähne aus da sitzt dann Steffen
coutrey energiepolitischer Sprecher der
AFD und treibt den echten Klimaexperten
mojitativ in den Wahnsinn und wenn Sie
jetzt genau hingucken zeigt uns der
Professor seine Verzweiflung am Ende
durch subtile Körpersprache und jetzt
setzen Sie sich hier hin und sagen es
stimmt nicht aber
stimmt nicht so argumentieren
das Gegenteil ist der Fall und alleine
deswegen müssen schon die alleine doch
nicht stören
ja
der Nobelpreis für Mittelfinger
geht dann Moschee herzlichen Glückwunsch
ja ich weiß nicht ob sie es gesehen
haben es war wirklich eine Sendung wie
ein Verkehrsunfall wie will man jemanden
argumentativ Stellen der Fakten schlicht
nicht akzeptiert ja du wirst verrückt
aber gut so läuft das heutzutage ja so
läuft das heutzutage Fakten sind für die
letztlich auch nur Meinung das heißt
wenn die AFD mal regiert laufen
Abi-Prüfungen wahrscheinlich so in
welchem Jahr wurde denn Karl der Große
gekrönt
1978 Bautzen nein das war 800 in Rom
glaube ich nicht da habe ich andere
Information
okay
durchgefallen nee bestanden tschüss
guter Mann wird garantiert
Bildungsminister im ersten Kabinett
höcke 2016 haben noch 17 Prozent der
Deutschen gesagt die AFD sei eine
normale demokratische Partei heute sind
es schon 27 Prozent gut vielleicht liegt
das auch in ihrer cleveren social
media-arbeit hier Deutschland auf dem
Weg zur DDR 2.0 bald gibt es keine
Bananen mehr Leute
hallo ich bin im Vergleich die CSU die
aktuell völlig sachlich twittert Nein zu
staatlicher heizungsspionage ja
mit ihrem Robert in der Rolle des
perversen Spanners
gerade beim Thema grüne unterscheidet
sich der Ton der Union nur noch graduell
von der AFD Leute wie oft denn noch
Abschreiben von denen bringt nichts es
will nur noch mehr Leute das Original ja
es bringt nichts
afd-position werden damit schleichend
normalisiert auch durch sowas hier
Stichwort Asylrecht man sieht in der
grünen Partei auch 0,0 Bewegung oder
Bereitschaft etwas zu tun das ist aber
nicht die Meinung der Bürgermeister und
Landräte das ist nicht die Meinung der
Ministerpräsidenten und deswegen muss
auch über eine Grundgesetzänderung
gesprochen werden genau einfach mit
Tipp-Ex entschlacken das alle
Grundgesetz ne ja übrigens im letzten
Jahr wurde nur in 0,8% der Fälle Asyl
nach Artikel 16A Grundgesetz gewähren
der Rest nach Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention eine Änderung
Rechte also gar nichts Kretschmer macht
ohne Not afd-förderung salonfähig für
erfolgreichen Populismus ist es nämlich
auch wichtig wer was sagt verstehen sie
Faustregel je harmloser und niedlicher
der Absender desto besser
kalt von wegen Klimawandel scheiß grüne
merkt euch das Kinder sie lügen immer
weil sie böse sind liegt auf Orban hat
völlig recht ich baue jetzt auch ein
Grenzzaun können wir das schaffen jawohl
mein führ
man muss es nur wirklich rüberbringen so
das ist jetzt die große Frage was hilft
gegen die AFD neueste Idee der Union das
Bundesprogramm Patriotismus unter
anderem soll der 23 mai der Geburtstag
unseres Grundgesetzes endlich Feiertag
werden das fordert Philipp amth ja gut
der Philipp war zwar 1949 noch nicht
dabei sieht aber so aus
ich meine keine Frage Verfassungs
patriotismus ist nie verkehrt in unserem
Grundgesetz stehen wirklich viele Sachen
auf die man stolz sein kann hier die
konkreten Vorschläge der CDU unter
anderem solle die Nationalhymne häufiger
bei öffentlichen Anlässen gesungen
werden dazu sollte Deutschlandflagge im
öffentlichen Raum sichtbar sein von
einer neuen
identifikationsgefühl sollte demnach vor
allem auch Ausländer und ostdeutsche
profitieren
moment mal ostdeutsche sind gar keine
Ausländer
ja im cdu-an da steht wirklich es müsse
einen besonderen Einsatz für
patriotische Fragen in Ostdeutschland
geben weil da die afd-zahlen so gut sind
Idee meinerseits würde da statt mehr
fahren nicht eher konkrete Politik
helfen endlich gleiche Löhne in Ost und
West zum Beispiel oder wir sagen einfach
ab jetzt ist immer WM ja klar ja
natürlich denn wenn WM ist funktioniert
das ja mit dem unverkrampften
Patriotismus und ich habe übrigens auch
gar nichts gegen unsere Hymne ist ein
schönes Lied
[Musik]
nee ist doch kein schönes Lied merke
die Patriotismus Offensive der Union sie
ist bestimmt gut gemeint auch wenn sich
Emotionen bekanntlich nicht von oben
verordnen lassen an der CDU-Basis geben
sie trotzdem alles Martin klemmt nur
leitet einen CDU Ortsverband in
Paderborn er und seine Freunde sind
hellauf begeistert vom neuen
Bundesprogramm Patriotismus
so leute wir als CDU fordern dass die
Nationalhymne öfter gesungen wird sehr
gut
und Recht und Freiheit entschuldigung
ich rede gerade du hast doch gerade eben
gesagt wir müssen jetzt häufiger singen
ja aber nicht wenn ich rede ja es war
doch gerade voll interessant ich
ich patriotische Gefühle bei den Bürgern
könnte man auch anders erzeugen zum
Beispiel mit Ice die pünktlich sind und
mit weniger Unterrichtsausfall und mit
schnellem Internet
[Gelächter]
Osten wir machen das mit den Fahnen das
ist viel realistischer ja das sieht doch
gestern schon ganz gut als wir da
zusammen in der Stadt die Leute für das
Grundgesetz begeistert haben guten Tag
ich bin von der CDU und würde gerne mit
Ihnen über das Grundgesetz sprechen
kein Bock auf Grundgesetz wie falls oder
was das gut sein und dann haben wir noch
die Sichtbarkeit der Bundesflagge aber
sowas von erhöht
[Musik]
mein Auto
großartig gelaufen Freunde
was haben wir hier noch Moment der
Reichstag wird ein Zentrum patriotischer
selbstvergewässerung etwa durch Porträts
bedeutender Parlamentarier
Leute das doch die Idee
auch für zu Hause
[Musik]
was ist los Schatz stimmt das nicht ich
kann das doch nicht wenn der zuguckt
warte warte wir können doch die
Deutschlandfahne über den haben die
drüber da kann er uns nicht zuschauen
Hase
sorry
und bevor die Laune zu gut wird reden
wir jetzt mal über Personalmangel
konkret über den bei der deutschen
Polizei immer mehr Auszubildende
brechende ab und auch die Bewerberzahlen
sinken ja aber woran liegt
woran liegt fragt man sich macht am
Mittwoch den Fernseher an sieht wie in
Bremen Polizisten von linksextremen mit
Flaschen und Steinen geworfen werden und
merkt ja deswegen ja natürlich vom
täglichen Alltagswahnsinn im deutschen
Nachtleben mal ganz zu schweigen doch
die Polizei stellt doch illegale Waffen
sicher so wie dieses Klappmesser das ein
15-jähriger Junge mit sich trug er sagte
wenn jemand in den schlafstock auf ihn
zukommt dann hat er Messer um sich zu
verteidigen ich habe vorhin eine andere
Situation gehabt hat jemand einen
Schlagstock gehabt der auch verboten ist
heute hier und der wollte sich damit
verteidigen wenn jemand mit Messer auf
ihn zukommt
warum nur wollen immer weniger Leute
Polizist werden ein Rätsel in einer
Umfrage sagen 60 Prozent der
Schichtdienst leisten sie leiden unter
Schlafstörungen und psychischen
Problemen ja Polizisten machen
regelmäßig traumatische Erfahrung aber
verpflichtende Supervision wird aktuell
leider nur in Berlin aufgebaut dabei
stehen nicht wenige Beamte kurz vor dem
Burnout wer hilft den ich kann es ihnen
sagen am besten wir alle ja natürlich
jeder kann mithelfen die Klima Kleber
zum Beispiel festkleben ist ja okay aber
vielleicht nur mit Tesafilm dann geht
das wegtragen schneller und als bitte an
den schwarzen Block vielleicht einfach
mal differenzieren euren Sprechern
so geht doch und vor der Demo am besten
selber das Pfefferspray ins Gesicht
sprühen das spart auch enorme Zeit
ich finde satire darf auch mal sagen
wenn was gut läuft die Ampel setzt jetzt
ein
bundespolizeibeauftragten ein die erste
unabhängige Kontrolle Instanz für
Polizei auf Bundesebene sein oder ihr
Job Missstände und Fehlverhalten bei der
Polizei feststellen identifiziert acht
Bundesländer haben schon so einen
Beauftragten und das ist eine gute Idee
denn bisher läuft das ja so bei uns bei
ungerechtfertigter Polizei Gewalt
ermitteln Polizisten gegen Polizisten
sehen Sie der gute alte chorgeist nur 2%
der Ermittlung enden mit einer Anklage
nehmen wir mal diesen Fall den Fall
eines Kölners der von Polizisten
misshandelt wurde das ähm hinterlässt
auf jeden Fall tiefe Spuren also dass
man kein Vertrauen mehr hat in die
Polizei aber auch in den Rechtsstaat
nicht mehr ganze vier Jahre dauerte es
bis ein Gericht entschied dass Sven
Wille Unrecht geschehen war ja erst nach
vier Jahren und auch nur weil eine junge
Polizei Schülerin am Ende doch für den
Mann ausgesagt hat unabhängige
Meldestellen in allen Bundesländern
wären doch auch für die große Masse der
korrekt Arbeit in Polizisten eine gute
Sache im Moment muss noch sehr viel
passieren damit es zu einer Anklage
kommt dann müsste der Beamte schon weiß
ich nicht ein Bild von sich und dem
verprügelten bei insta Posten dabei
seine Dienstmarke verlieren aus Versehen
in einen Eimer Farbe treten und
Fußspuren zurück bis zu seiner Wache
hinterlassen hallo grüß Dich und da dann
sämtliche Kollegen Frauen dann wird
vielleicht ermittelt vielleicht mehr
Transparenz ja mehr Transparenz hilft
immer deshalb gibt's ja in fast allen
Bundesländern die Kennzeichnungspflicht
und immer öfter bodycams in NRW zum
Beispiel längst Standard so auch neulich
bei dem völlig aus dem Ruder gelaufenen
Einsatz in Dortmund als ein 16-Jähriger
Asylbewerber durch Schüsse aus einer
Polizei Maschinenpistole getötet wurde
doch ausgerechnet bei diesem Einsatz
blieben alle Kameras aus aus Stress so
heißt es später hätten alle Beamten
vergessen Sie einzuschalten
jo 12 Kameras und keine einzige läuft
das nenne ich wirklich eine miese
Einschaltquote meine Damen und Herren
tatsächlich entscheiden die Beamten
selber ob und wann sie die Kameras
Einschalten die Polizei darf das
Material im Nachhinein sogar löschen
aber nochmal die ganz große Mehrheit
aller Polizisten und Polizisten macht
einen guten Job unter oft sehr extremen
Bedingungen und natürlich kommt man an
dosierter Gewaltanwendung manchmal nicht
vorbei hier kindgerecht erklärt im
Tigerentenclub
[Musik]
könnte sein dass da einer nachträglichen
Geräusch draufgelegt hat ich will es
nicht völlig ausschließen
Fachkräftemangel in fast allen Branchen
ein Problem aber bei der Polizei ist es
wirklich dramatisch reden wir darüber
mit Matthias Matschke er unterrichtet am
Bundespolizei Ausbildungszentrum im
hessischen Eschwege wo heute eine neue
Klasse ihren ersten Tag hat er Matschke
zu wenig Nachwuchs woran liegt's
ein Fall für Kommissar ob wir es ja
woran liegt das nur ab Dauerstress den
unzähligen Überstunden oder daran dass
manche Kollegen von ihrem Gehalt keine
Familie ernähren können das werden jetzt
mal der erste Spuren den ich nachgehen
würde wenn ich die Zeit hätte habe ich
aber nicht dämliche scheiß Frage
also damit wir uns nicht falsch
verstehen ich habe größten Respekt vor
jedem der ihre Arbeit macht ich könnte
das nicht ja seid ja auch nie eine
behauptet ja weil Wikipedia steht sie
haben Germanistik studiert und ich sag
mal so wenn irgendwo ein Verbrechen
passiert hört man ja eher selten den
Satz oh schnell ruf mal einen
Germanisten am besten mit Übergewicht
ich Ihnen denn getan jetzt hör doch auf
was wir uns alles anhören müssen in
diesem undankbaren hier steht bis
hierhin gehört mir einer Uniform gehört
mir
gefunden von mir Mann sein
hey hey hey nein nein nein
[Musik]
also ich würde lieber nach Hause gehen
da ich auch geht aber nicht weil wir
jeden Mann und jede Frau brauchen dabei
haben wir die Anforderungen schon
gesenkt in NRW brauchst du kein Abi mehr
und Kommissar zu werden hier bei der
Bundespolizei gibt es nicht mal mehr
eine Mindestgröße wir würden sogar Peter
Maffay einstellen
hallo guten Tag ja sorry ich weiß ich
bin viel zu spät aber es gab ein ganz
schlimm Notfall ich schwöre ich muss
wirklich ganz dringend meine hässliche
Uniform umstyle ja und du sagst gleich
ich habe nicht viel Zeit ich parken
ja wie gesagt wir haben die
Anforderungen extrem gesenkt
Frau Larissa bitte einfach mal hinsetzen
und mit der Uniform das geht natürlich
gar nicht oh danke schön dass sie ihn
aufgefallen ist übelst schön geworden
ich weiß
ja
damit muss ich arbeiten so erste Frage
an die neue Klasse warum wollen sie zur
Bundespolizei was treibt sie an
weiß es nicht ja Frau Larissa bitte ja
also bei mir da gab es ein ganz
signifikantes schüssel-erlebnis
und zwar habe ich mal als ich noch ein
Kind gewesen war den Film Police Academy
gesehen
oh Gott meine Güte der war so
unglaublich lustig gewesen ich schwöre
ich habe so heftig gelacht ja und die
haben doch so ein Spaß bei der Polizei
Schule und das ist doch immer so ein
Mann und der kann täuschend echt
Geräusche nachmachen z.B macht er so ein
Hund so
und dann macht er einmal mit deinen
Katze
und der kann was können wir noch Polizei
Siri das klingt so
Larissa Larissa wir kennen alle die
bescheuerten
polisee warum sind sie hier Ding
politische kenne mich ja aber natürlich
nicht nur ich bitte Sie auch wegen Geld
ja und ich bin neulich in Berlin
drauf oh Kopf ab beautiful und dadurch
vermischt das wie ein Blitz warte mal
warte mal Larissa dachte ich beautiful
das bin ich ja der Rest ist Geschichte
okay whatever
vergessen wir die Theorie in der Praxis
fragen uns heute woran erkenne ich dass
ich in einer rechten chat-gruppe
gelandet bin zum Beispiel an den emojis
ich habe hier mal drei Beispiele eine
Torte die Aubergine und das Hitler
Einhorn
eins davon ist rechts na richtig die
Torte weil sie Braut ist so wer von euch
hat den schon mal Erfahrungen mit einer
rechten chat-gruppe gemacht
oder linke weiß ich jetzt nicht weil
also bei mir da gehen die Chats immer so
von oben nach unten aber gut dass Sie
diesbezüglich schreiben weil ich habe
eine Gruppe mit zwei Freundinnen Jessica
und äh da hatten wir natürlich ein ganz
schlimm Streit es ist wirklich völlig
eskaliert weil mein ernsthaft man darf
nicht lesen muss damit schlagen muss da
kombinieren und ich habe geschrieben
doch deswegen darf man wohl muss man
nichts ist gerade voll modern erstmal
drei Prinzessin Obergrenze und deswegen
so äh du bist voll der Fashion Magazin
doch wieder deine Mut an und ich so ja
das hat genau die richtige rot gefärbte
Haare aber pink tragen hast du
und dann Messing so ja als nächstes
kommst Du vielleicht mit tennisturbe und
ich bin im Vorruhestand ne tschüss ja
auf jeden Fall habe ich dann nestrin
geschrieben du kannst mich mal und dann
habe ich sie geblockt weil ganz ehrlich
mit solchen Leuten will ich bei Whatsapp
nicht gesehen werden
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
hallo Leute Ich bin's der
[Musik]
heute-ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
Scheiß und liegt
dann abonniert jetzt den Kanal
was zur Hölle ist ein Ersteller
[Musik]